today on karen's gone wild
these kids are basically playing a game
that we all have played but on april 29
what seemed like a harmless game
ended with one student getting seriously
hurt according to the boy's mother who
asked we not show her face
he has a rare medical condition making
head injuries especially dangerous
according to a police report during that
game another
student threw a ball at his face on
purpose he
sustained facial tissue damage to his
face he had a black eye and a bruised
nose
records show the then fourth grader also
suffered a concussion
his condition is something kamishi
lindley says she and her son bryce
knew nothing about wednesday bryce was
charged with aggravated assault
i couldn't believe it this is on top of
a one-day suspension which occurred
right after the incident
this is a kid that was playing on the
playground with his friends i tried not
to let it get to this point this mother
claiming her son had been hurt before
and that she reported it to the school
my son was hit
twice in the face of the ball previously
due to this and the child apologized to
my son and he said mom it's okay
we're still going to be friends i'm
unaware of any of those situations
sorry that her child got hurt
i'd be sorry for any child that got hurt
lindley just wishes
problems like this could be solved in
the classroom not the court
honestly here's the downside to this
right
you've won charged another child with
potential assault and
made them irreparably afraid of law
enforcement in jail for no reason
two you've infantilized your child to
the point where it's unhealthy
and if i found out it's not if i found
out my mom
charged another young boy in my school
because we played on the playground
and he hit me too hard i would look at
my mom some type of way
and also you're robbing him of the
chance to go through life and try to
figure some things out
i'm not saying that your kid is not at
risk and there's certain things it's not
like this kid came and fed him a peanut
butter sandwich and used allergy okay
you know what i mean that's very such to
me so i don't know i just think
you're sending not only the wrong
message to the other child but also to
your own
and uh it's not something i would
recommend some things
a kid has to figure out for himself
unless he's being abused
you know unless he's going that far
that's that's what i would say
dodgeball dodgeball breath can i just
say
dodgeball if you knew how to through
those balls
was the best game to play during gym
class
we used to [ __ ] people up the whole
point of the game was like
pick up pick it up you about to get
smacked i can still remember the sound
of
a guy
[Laughter]
i remember that and it was always
impressive when you launch at someone to
catch in their chest and then you know
they're going to throw it back at you
yeah
so you got to figure out if you're going
to dodge or you're going to jump or how
about when it's you versus four people
yeah and you gotta try to take them out
it's like dodgeball is a great game it's
great
it's though but that's besides the point
it's not about how
is it though is it though i mean they
was playing dodgeball this kid got a
concussion i'd say he did his job
am i lie was we not trying to [ __ ]
people up that was i mean i'm not trying
to
people you know anything but listen when
i had the ball
you were cruel when you played dodgeball
like i remember one time a kid was
reaching for a ball
and then we were supposed to wait and i
had my ball and i was waiting at the
line i was like uh-huh uh-huh
and the kid grabbed the ball and they
were supposed to go back to the line and
i just smacked him behind the head
and the point of the point is not to
hurt people
the point of no game is to hurt people
except dodgeball
yeah it really is the whole thing it's
not to hurt you
i want it's not for you to hurt okay
okay i don't want you to be
broken i don't want you to like to be
hurt i'm gonna
i'm gonna pin you with the ball but i
don't the point is not to have a
concussion
no i'm having a no that's not the point
that the wrong boom
yeah but i'm not god no that's not the
point but pain is the point
without pain not catching the ball pain
and
and getting hurt is a byproduct of you
playing games
it's a byproduct it's not the point of
it but it's a byproduct of it
okay maybe it wasn't for you so i'm
gonna that's your experience that's you
because you just wanna pull up number
got angry you used to throw it
hard i know you wanna hurt people and
that's some issues you're gonna have to
do
you know they have a pre-existing
condition
so your kid the kid the kid mom knew
what does have to do with the kid and
does the mom know i'm coming
not the mom of the kid that got charged
but the mom of the kid the mother of the
kid was
when he had a prison so tell your kid
not to play dodgeball
you're not you're the one that's not
supposed to play dodgeball
so what your kid catches something he
goes he goes for halloween
trick-or-treating he gets a candy
there's peanuts in there you're gonna
charge the person that gave him the kid
to the peanut
check your [ __ ] you're the one with the
pre-existing condition
i'ma check all your candies if you have
a pre-existing condition that makes you
have concussion
for nothing and head injuries and
something else
i'm not i'm gonna be i'm gonna be like
hey you know what uh gym class
you're exempt from that you're not going
to gym class you're gonna draw
we can't have you dying my mommy doesn't
push you for 17 hours
she got stitched up we're not fitting to
lose you right now over a dodgeball game
you better sit you better sit your
behind right there
sit your behind there don't play no
dodge ball that's your responsibility as
a parent
i don't know that's what i would do you
know what i mean or
the school if they're aware of his
condition i wouldn't even go to the
school
i'd be like see it's your behind boy
you fit in the dot i'm not gonna charge
the person that played dodgeball
they don't oh whatever you just read the
title it's already stupid enough as it
is it's like what are you doing here
what is going on what are we doing oh
this is not a 10 minute video
we're talking about a boy being charged
for assault for dodgeball
honestly i hope he gets off scot-free
and i hope he wears it as a badge of
honor
[ __ ] i murk this kiss so bad and then
dodgeball
come catch these balls paws
now thankfully there's an update to the
story and the charges were dropped
but just the fact that there were
charges what does it even mean when a
police department charges someone with
this
what does that even mean well they're
they're they're
their point you know the police are not
there to think
that's not their job yeah just to
enforce the law enforce the law
you want to charge that person because
of that i'm gonna fill up the paper
is it dumb or not that's not my job my
job is to enforce the law how do you
know a ten-year-old could be charged
with assault
yeah anything any anybody could be
charged with assault really
we used to have gym sanction dodgeball
bro imagine that
whole bunch of balls inside the
gymnasium everyone have to play
including the girls including the girls
hey girl tamara you want to go to prom
no okay i'll see you at dodgeball
her up tamara what's up
never went to prom but i still gave her
some of these licks
if you guys feel some type of way about
this thing we want to hear your comments
but leave it below
all right let's get it i like i like
what you said about
oh oh you don't want to go to the spring
okay that's really happening yo i used
to [ __ ] up my crushes
that was super toxic super toxic
okay brittany to be fair to be fair
all the women would most of them except
for like a couple of tomboys would give
up
fairy tales yes they would start let's
go sit down
yes and talk this one out
[Music]
is
you